si beaucoup ça marche le micro
alors
donc on va maintenant passer au débat
donc on va procéder de la manière
suivante donc
michel jayat va commencer vers le
plaisir de commencer donc par
avec un commentaire d'à peu près 10
minutes puis moi je vais heureux
également ensuite parlé à peu près dix
minutes et ensuite on pourra ouvrir des
questions à la salle à la salle il ya
quelqu'un qui va passer avec un micro et
comme ça vous pourrez interagir avec
soin les réalisateurs du film qui sont
ici emmanuel blanchard et fabrice ali né
et où avec donc je présente rapidement
le colonel goya ce qui a donc le
un double parcours un parcours à la fois
avec dans l'armée une expérience
opérationnelle et un parcours de
chercheur donc il a publié de nombreux
livres donc je vais en citer que deux un
premier la chair et d'acier qui avait
publié en 2004 l'armée française est
l'invention de la guerre moderne donc là
qui est sur la période précédente 14 18
et le dernier en 2014 sous le feu la
mort comme hypothèse de travail et donc
il a publié ses livres les surtout il a
un blog sur lequel il est très actif qui
s'appelle la voix de l'épée est qui et
qui est une source d'information très
précieuse pour les chercheurs sur les
questions de défense en france donc je
laisse la parole à michel boyon
merci j'entendais
ont d'abord je tiens à celui le qualité
de ce film de faire remarquable c'est
tout à fait saisissant
et
puis c'est toujours comment dire mettre
des images en derrière les concepts
historique voir concrètement ce que ce
que ça donne c'est toujours mettre de la
chair derrière les les concepts c'est
toujours évidemment beaucoup plus fort
alors pour pour commenter j'ai d'abord
fait un petit peu
revenir sur sur certains éléments
d'avoir revenir sur les événements sur
l'origine en fait de cette idée qui
paraît
monstrueuse de
frapper
directement des populations d'écraser
des populations sur sous les bombes
l'origine en vient
elle était la première pendant la
première guerre mondiale où on a déjà
une première tentative de
faire craquer l'idée étant de faire
craquer les états on est dans première
guerre mondiale d'un point de vue
militaire son ensemble est une grande
guerre de siège rien ne bouge et puis et
puis on se dit tiens bombe dans cette
guerre de siège comme pendant les sièges
des villes la métaphore est là on va
essayer d' affamer de faire pression sur
sur l'ensemble de la population pour que
pour aboutir un effondrement
et il ya deux remarques pour la première
c'est que
d'abord on va essayer de toutes les
manières possibles on va bombarder un
pari va être bombardées par l'artillerie
allemande on bombarde directement la
population civile londres sera bombardée
par des haies plein par par des avions
etc
au passage là
les alliés font la même chose la france
bon bordent la ville de kars cours d'un
bombardement de roddy de représailles ou
en boire directement la ville à ma
connaissance en 1916 c'est à ma
connaissance le seul cas où la france
est pratiqué ce genre de choses deux
raids visant directement les populations
mais la deuxième remarque c'est que on
s'aperçoit que malgré tout ça fonctionne
c'est à dire que la guerre se termine
par des effondrements d'état en russie
et aussi en allemagne
alors ses pales sont pas les
bombardements qui ont provoqué ça mais
il ya quand même cette idée que
effectivement on peut faire provoqué des
effondrements
part en faisant pression sur sur la
population
un discernement eux mêmes d'ailleurs
contribueront à cette idée avec l'idée
du coup de poignard dans le dos et ce
toute sa propagande nazie qui dit voilà
c'est pas n'ont pas été vaincues c'est
la révolution celle intérieure qui nous
a qui nous a vaincu donc il ya cette
idée que l'on peut provoquer
l'effondrement de l'intérieur et
ça plus effectivement il faut ajouter un
autre facteur qui est aussi important
c'est un facteur très corporatistes
c'est à dire que toutes ces armes et
moderne cette armée de l'air qui
apparaissent en
pendant la guerre et surtout appris
qu'ils apparaissent de manière plus ou
moins autonomes qui luttent pour leur
autonomie elles vont aussi jouer cette
carte en disant voilà de nous armer leur
nous pouvons remporter la victoire à
nous tous tout seul pas besoin de se
relancer dans des batailles atroce
comme comme celle de verdun où la somme
afin sur leurs pas la peine de revenir à
cette guerre et nous nous sommes
capables de en bombardant
l'ennemi en bombardant de ces centres
névralgiques on parle plutôt de
production industrielle à ce moment là
on peut
on peut paralyser tout un pays et
provoqué son enfant nombre a donc remis
à comprendre que dans l'esprit de ces
gens là
c'est une manière
cc c'est une guerre humanitaire
quasiment pas ce que ça va éviter de
reproduire les souffrances de la
première guerre mondiale en obtenant une
victoire beaucoup plus
rapides qu'eux
qu'à ce moment là et bien comme on le
voit en réalité on baigne un peu dans
une illusion illusion qui va s'avérer
meurtrière
à l'été on hésite dans cette perspective
on hésite encore beaucoup il ya encore
des réticences
morales
très forte je rappelle que dans les
toutes les conventions toutes les
conventions
de la haie et autres
saint pétersbourg et autres interdisent
de frapper directement la population
civile et et on a là c'est quelque chose
très bien montré dans le film qui est
dans l'air c'est vous dire dans les
années d'avant guerre mais mais il ya
quand même un beau gros blocage lorsque
la guerre commence roosevelt demande à
toutes les nations c'est d'interdire de
tous les belligérants de conduire de
d'accepter le principe de ne pas
bombarder les villes et c'est voilà
c'est respecter pratiquement jusqu'à
jusqu'à mai 1940 premiers bombardements
sur l'allemagne semble au bord de man
avec des tracts
et ses premiers projectiles à tomber sur
l'allemagne sont des tracts en réalité
mais et puis tout saute et puis le
verrou saute et puis on sait très bien
montré il ya tout un engrenage
psychologique qui se met en place il ya
une escalade dans la terreur qui est qui
peut d'une certaine façon apparaître
complètement irrationnel là aussi
c'était montrer les britanniques
résistent aux bombardements ce qui n'est
pas prévu un il se passe des phénomènes
aussi psychologiques qu'on a anticipé on
n'a pas anticipé on a étudié ce
phénomène dès cette époque que que les
populations ont pensé qu'ils auraient
effectivement que la population
craquerait que les hôpitaux avaient
prévu des hôpitaux psychiatriques
tout autour de la ville de londres mais
finalement ces hôpitaux resté vide et
qu' il ya des phénomènes qui se passe
parmi ceux qui ne sont pas directement
touchés parle par les frappes
deux phénomènes de deux sortes de
compensations de résistance
qui est qui n'était pas du tout été
anticipé et donc ça ne marche pas ça ne
marche pas ça ça ne trouve pas
à moins de frais faire pratiquer à très
grande échelle ça ne provoque pas
d'effondrement de la population mais
malgré tout on fait la même chose aux
allemands
alors qu'on sait que ça ne marche pas
quoi alors derrière on s'abrite vers des
des arguments
culturels voire racistes en dix ans mais
nous on résiste mais les allemands sont
beaucoup plus faibles que nous et le
discours allemand d'ailleurs est
absolument inverse et et tout ça on
bascule dans l'aigu rationalité les
armes v
donc ils sont lancés dans sur sur
l'angleterre se sont aussi vus
représailles en allemand
en fait elles n'ont aucune justification
militaire et même c'est un détournement
de ressources complètement irrationnel
tous les efforts tous que ça a pu coûter
l'allemagne
et auraient pu être consacrés à autre
chose en terme d'efforts de guerre mais
non c'est en s'est lancé dans un effort
qui est qui s'avère complètement
irrationnel donc il ya tout un
enchaînement sorte de folie collective
qui
qui qui se met en place qui s'arrête à
la fin de la guerre donc à juste après
après hiroshima il ya quand même une
sorte de
de retour sur terre d'une certaine façon
notamment en angleterre dire que on se
rend compte un petit peu quand même de
la folie dans laquelle on a basculé
c'était ok harris bombers harris mis un
peu bien l'écart cherche il se vante pas
trop de ce qui s'est passé donc il ya il
ya une remise en question du côté
britannique côté américain non et on va
continuer à utiliser cette puissance
aérienne appel salaires power
pour essayer à nouveau de d'écraser
complètement d'englober complètement
l'ennemi et de frappe est complètement
le on appelle ça le système et demi pour
essayer d'obtenir sa capitulation au
moins une modification de son
comportement si les américains arrêtés
qui pendant longtemps ne font ça les
autres pays ne font pas là on n'a pas du
tout évoqué les soviétiques soviétique
aura pu là aussi de lancer campagne de
bombardements ils ne le font pas c'est
pas du tout dans leur façon de voir les
choses c'est une pratique est
essentiellement américaine en a des
moyens aériens que seuls dont seuls nous
disposons et nous en profitons pour
pour écraser pour faire pression sur
l'adversaire ce sera le cas encore et ce
sera le cas au vietnam à chaque fois
d'ailleurs ça
c'est vraiment ses choix et ça revient
ses revenus effectivement au goût du
jour après la guerre froide
donc d'un puck que nous connaissons
essentiellement pour pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que
c'est parce que c'est possible là aussi
pendant seconde guerre mondiale les
britanniques le bon beurre commandes
enfin frappe l'allemagne parce que c'est
possible parce que c'est possible et que
même il n'y a pas beaucoup d'autres
options en réalité est donc là on se
retrouve une situation où les américains
disposent
d'une force aérienne considérable voilà
il n'y a pas d'opposition ils risquent
rien on risque rien à utiliser ces ses
avions et donc bâtons qu'on les utilise
un canton
proverbe américain qui dit voilà quand
on a
qu'un marteau comme outil en raison de
tous les problèmes en terme de coût
quand on dispose d'une puissance
aérienne on va modeler finalement tout
notre façon de faire pour pour pouvoir
appliquer pour pouvoir l'utiliser et
donc effectivement on va se lancer dans
des campagnes et israéliens feront
sensiblement adopteront ce principe avec
cette idée que on transfère en réalité
on transfert du risque on transfert du
risque de nos soldats on évite de
de prendre des risques pour cela en
agissant de manière indirecte par parler
par les frappes le problème étant que là
aussi ça ne d'abord il ya un premier
problème c'est que quoi qu'on fasse
quelle que soit la précision il y aura
toujours des pertes civiles
la campagne au kosovo a fait au moins
1500 morts là actuellement en irak le
campagne coalition en irak en syrie a
fait à peu près 5000 morts actuellement
donc quoi qu'il arrive malgré tout ce
que tous les efforts et même s'il n'ya
pas la volonté de frapper directement la
population cette année +1 et plat ça
fait malgré tout des pertes civiles et
puis ensuite c'est pas efficace
militairement c'est pas efficace parce
que il est relativement facile
militairement de se soustraire à ça il
suffit de s'enterrer de se cacher de se
disperser de se mettre en syrie et c'est
donc ce n'est pas efficace en soit ça
peut on peut obtenir quelques effets si
on est face à des gens qui acceptent de
négocier il ya eu quelques cas la serbie
éventuellement mais quand on est face à
quelqu'un qui ne veut pas négocier là ça
devient de ce coup beaucoup plus
problématique donc les campagnes
aériennes pratique encore une fois
américaine essentiellement nous français
on a fait mener le plein de campagne
on n'a jamais pratiqué
cela
mais
et donc pratique américaine donc
pratiquer globalement des coalitions si
on veut s'associer aux américains il
faut faire en jouant on fait à
l'américaine donc nous français en irak
en syrie ont participé essentiellement
une coalition une coalition qui fait des
frappes mais grand dans l'esprit que
voilà faut garder à l'esprit que ça ne
marche que ça ne fonctionne ça n'a
d'effet
stratégique que c'est en réalité si
l'adversaire le veut bien et veut bien
négociés face à des groupes armés face à
des états dont
7 pouces et on a vu que ça peut ça peut
effectivement être des moins efficaces
face à des groupes armés incrustés dans
la population des groupes radicaux
en revanche ça devient beaucoup plus
problématique et on a assez peu
d'exemples de
quelques gens mais assez peu d'exemples
où c'est réussi et on se retrouve en
situation
où depuis 2001 depuis l'an septembre
2001 estime que les américains ont
réalisé sans bill frappe
100000 frappe 100000 frappes aériennes
depuis 2001 dans le monde entier
avec un monde enfin front qui s'était
rendu lui même au monde entier qu'il a
plu qui n'a plus véritablement de
limites
et avec cette
fin avec des résultats que là aussi on
qui sont assez
assez assez assez limité pour terminer
voilà c'est à dire qu'on surtout une
situation où
où les pertes civiles en transférant le
le risque aux pertes civiles dont
on aboutit à des guerres où ce sont des
civils qui tombe essentiellement
beaucoup plus que de cela beaucoup plus
que ceux-là américain beaucoup plus de
soldats de la coalition et même
maintenant cette situation où
l'adversaire est capable de riposter par
des attentats
sur les territoires nationaux en france
en particulier ou même de notre côté ce
sont aussi des civils qui équipaient qui
payent ce type de guerre voilà qu'on
reparle
de tout ça
donc justement donc monsieur andry
précisément sur cette question des
civils puisque moi ce qui m'a marqué
dans ce documentaire c'est deux points
en particulier c'est comment on les
civils à partir donc de la seconde
guerre mondiale font partie de la
stratégie militaire et donc sont
utilisés comme comme justement
une arme et la deuxième point que je
trouve très intéressant c'est cette
question de la technologie est ce que la
technologie permet de protéger
finalement ces populations civiles est
donc d'aller vers une guerre propre ou
est-ce que cette technologie elle est
aussi porteuse de d'autant plus de
destructions donc ce qui est intéressant
dans le documentaire et que j'aimerai
aussi souligner ici c'est que on voit
deux manières de penser la stratégie
aérienne et l'utilisation de l'armé
aérienne qui s'entremêlent il ya une
première manière de l'utiliser qui est
une manière punitive c'est à dire qu'on
va essayer c'est des stratégies dites
d'attrition donc on va essayer de viser
les populations civiles afin de
démoraliser l'ennemi et afin de rompre
en faite le le le soutien de la
population à un gouvernement et donc de
délégitimer le gouvernement donc ça
c'est très bien montré dans les
bombardements
keith qui sont faits sur les villes
allemandes et c'est une stratégie qui a
été critiqué au niveau éthique elle a
été critiquée au niveau éthique parce
que précisément tout le problème ça va
être de mettre en balance une finalité
qui est donc toujours la finalité de la
paix et c'est ce que répète les
stratèges c'est à dire il faut
cibler ces civils puisque c'est comme ça
qu'on arrivera à la paix plus rapidement
et le moyen qui est donc la mort de ces
civils est un des problèmes
qui se posent dans cette question de
l'arbitrage ça va être là l'art est une
agence de la raison d'état enfin parce
que cette structure
qui met en balance la finalité et les
moyens elle est typique delà de la
raison d'état or ce qui est très
important également à cette époque enfin
plutôt à la fin de la guerre c'est le
les procès de nuremberg puisque cette
question éthique elle va être prise en
charge par le droit et c'est aux pros
moment des procès niant ambert que donc
on va mettre en place un système
coercitif de respect des normes puisque
le droit de la gare a existé avant mais
là on va on va l'appliquer et on va à le
tenir pour responsables les dirigeants
de l'aide des puissances de lax or tout
le problème ça va être là le problème de
la proportionnalité qui est énorme le
juridique qui dit si vous avez un
objectif militaire qui est assez
important vous avez le droit à un
certain nombre de dommages civils qui
sont dits des dommages collatéraux et
qui donc sont légaux et ce problème là
on voit qu'il se pose continuellement
dans les bombardements et qui se posent
quant aux événements aujourd'hui aussi
puisque ce qu'on entend
deux des frappes dans les différentes
coalitions ça va être toujours cette
question de combien de dommages
collatéraux sont faits et à quel point
ils sont justifiées ou pas sachant qu'il
ya quand même une évolution à ce niveau
là puisque en irak le nombre de dommages
collatéraux pour un objectif militaire
qui était considéré comme high value
target donc un objectif militaire de
premier plan c'était 17 civils donc 10 à
thiviers c'est à dire que vous étiez
toujours dans le ratio légal et donc
vous étiez pas susceptible d'être
passibles de crimes de guerre devant les
juridictions pénales internationales et
il a été réduit à 5 et à 3 en israël
donc on a quand même même si cette
question de la proportionnalité
on peut s'interroger sur le bien fondé
de la norme on a quand même une
réduction
des dommages civile donc ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est la
stratégie dite de déni donc qui est de
viser dès ce tracteur les secteurs
stratégiques donc les infrastructures
les communications donc là on n'est plus
du tout dans dans l'utilisation des
civils et ce qui est intéressant en fait
c'est que la postérité de ces stratégies
de enfin de déni elle est double elle
est d'une part dans les sanctions
économiques qui essayent de visé
justement les infrastructures des de
l'adversaire et elle est également dans
les stratégies de décapitation ou
d'assassinats ciblés ou là en fait toute
la rhétorique est déployée par la cia
ces devises et l'infrastructure de
l'organisation qui est en fait les le
corps d des adversaires notamment on va
essayer de cibler des personnes qui ont
des compétences stratégiques importantes
comme des artificiers donc on voit quand
même la permanence de ce type de
stratégie et enfin pour conclure
j'aimerais dire un mot de cette question
de la technologie puisque ce qu'on voit
très bien dans un film aussi c'est que
l'un des problèmes qui est posée pour
les gouvernements ça va être de protéger
les populations civiles et du coup qui
va être mis pour la protection des
propos des populations civiles donc ça
c'est une question qui va se poser avec
d'autant plus de force après la seconde
guerre mondiale que qu'on est dans un
contexte de guerre nucléaire et tout
problème ça va être de faire un
équilibre de la terreur nucléaire ça va
être de protéger les populations civiles
de d'éventuelles frappes or aujourd'hui
où est-ce qu'on en est dedans dans cette
question à propos de la de la protection
des populations civiles donc là il ya un
exemple qui est intéressant qui est
l'exemple israélien qui a fait un grand
gros effort de système antimissile et
qui a construit donc ce qui s'appelle
l'iphone donne c'est à dire le dôme
d'acier sur toutes les villes
israéliennes qui est en fait donc un
système antimissile une fois que vous
avez un missile qui arrive il va y avoir
un autre missile israélien cette fois
lancé qui va intercepter en vol les
roquettes et qui va les détruire or ça
c'est très problématique
donc c'est très efficace mais c'est très
problématique au niveau de la
justification au niveau du cou puisque
pour une roquette qui coûte à construire
à peu près 800 $ donc selon les
estimations de l'armée américaine vous
avez le coup d'une interception c'est
entre 20000 et 50 millions $ par
roquette
donc c'est énorme et c'est un vrai coup
pour qui doit être justifiée pour les
démocraties donc je m'arrêterai là j'ai
essayé de faire un peu un
panorama des questions qui sont posées
par ces programmes de bombardements
aujourd'hui est ce que vous voulez
ajouter un mot
merci beaucoup et peut-être juste vous
vous posez une première question c'est
que nous une des
donc le film montre un peu à la
naissance de ce qu'on appelait repower à
la fin de la guerre et les américains
ont envoyé des missions étudier
l'efficacité des bombardements en
allemagne et au japon les experts
eux-mêmes ou conclu que les résultats
est effectivement plus que mitigé mais
ils avaient ils ont une formule qui est
assez saisissante ils disent ça n'a pas
très bien marché mais pendant la
première guerre mondiale c'étaient
l'enfance et là c'est l'adolescence
l'adolescence on est un peu maladroit et
voilà mais on va on va un nouvel âge va
advenir on va arriver à la maturité du
bombardement moi je la première question
c'est est-ce que vous pensez que d'une
certaine manière on arrivait une forme
de maturité du bombardement à moi si je
peux juste ya un an parce que derrière
je mets en parler j'ai oublié ce qui est
très intéressant question là c'est que
pour les assassinats ciblés faire moi je
suis pas une spécialiste des
bombardements mais pour pour aller les
assassinats ciblés c'est tous les
débat très intense qui assurent
l'efficacité de cette technique c'est
précisément sur cette question c'est à
dire que on a des personnes qui vont
dire ça attaque énormément le moral des
organisations et sap recipe salles et
des organismes se précipitent leur chute
et il y en a d'autres qui vont dire mais
pas du tout ça renforce leur
détermination à combattre donc ça montre
juste la permanence incroyable de cet
institut stratégique aujourd'hui
rebondir
après la seconde guerre mondiale
la maturité ces normes atomique pour
beaucoup un camp après les bombardements
d'hiroshima et nagasaki effectivement on
aboutit enfin une décision et une
capitulation quelques jours plus tard
alors effectivement le pourquoi de la
capitulation reste quand même
assez assez problématique est possible
que le fait que l'urss soit entré en
guerre juste au même moment ait eu au
moins autant d'affluence
et que finalement ces armes
enfin ces bombardements ont peut-être
été le prétexte aussi pour essayer de
pour obtenir un groupe et un peu plus
honorable au japon mais pour les
américains pour un serviteur américain
l'arme atomique c'est un peu le serpent
surprise c'est à dire que tout de suite
après la seconde guerre mondiale ben ça
et finalement toute la défense
américaine sans s'organise autour de l'
arme atomique en disant ben voilà on a
plus besoin d'armé
on a des bombardiers des b 29 avec des
armes atomiques ça suffit ça suffit à
tous et donc on arrive c'est le point
ultime
et les tous les tenants les théoriciens
de l'air power où le praticien comme
curtis lemay qui sera le patron quand
même de l'arsenal atomique américain
qui va inspirer le docteur folamour ont
notamment le personnage docteur folamour
remparts en partie dans le film de
kubrick c'est pour eux ces voix là c'est
magique on est arrivé au sommet et puis
en fait survient la guerre de corée et
là que personne n'a vu et puis
finalement cette arme atomique on va pas
l'utiliser et puis
met
donc il ya cette idée de l'air power est
toujours en permanence est toujours
présente ça n'a pas marché mais la
prochaine fois ça marchera
parce que voilà on sera plus fort
plombent le plus précis et c'est bon en
réalité
des problèmes comme l'a évoqué problèmes
tactiques et des problèmes de coûts
effectivement
dans le conflit actuel eux
tu es en gros tu es en combattant de
l'état islamique pas pour la pollution
ça coûte 200 mille euros un seul bon
donc c'est tout ça c'est aussi des
problèmes de coût les avions tout ça ça
revient extraordinairement cher ça ne
fonctionne enfin ce que parce qu'il ya
en réalité s'il n'y a pas d'opposition
non plus
pendant la guerre du kippour les
israéliens avaient perdu 80 avions en
l'espace de deux jours on perdrait 80
avions vous américain perdait 80 avions
et je parle même pas de la france ça
serait un effondrement ce serait
militairement ce serait une catastrophe
quand c'est à dire qu'on a atteint un
niveau de sophistication de poids de 7,2
cette force qui est devenu absolument
phénoménale et qu'on donc du coup qui
est devenu assez fragile et pour encore
une fois l'efficacité
bon qui as est
toujours aussi mitigé parce que chaque
fois on se retrouve face à des individus
qui résiste qui s'adapte
on peut imaginer n'importe quelle
technologie bon 3 ya toujours des
adaptations et d'adaptation aux drones
armés adaptation au bombardier
bombardier de masse etc
d'ailleurs on a aussi quand même enfin
en libye l'idée c'était de faire
exclusivement une zone de donc une no
fly zone c'est à dire une zone
d'interdiction de l'utilisation des
espaces aériens et aujourd'hui on est
quand même de plus en plus dans des
contextes où le post bellum c'est à dire
ce qui se passe après l'intervention
doit aussi faire parti de l'utilisation
fin de la réflexion stratégique et
évidemment la puissance aérienne chance
à elle est laide pas forcément à la
reconstruction et à la manipulation de
la paix donc c'est tout un problème
alors on va peut-être ouvrir des
questions à la salle
s qui accueille un micro et quelques
micros du coup d'oeil à des micro avec
deux côtés on
va peut-être faire passer les micros est
ce qu'il ya des personnes qui ont des
questions
il ya une question là bas je vois en
fait j'essaie des projecteurs qui sont
un pays puissant dans le café steel 2
bonjour du coup ma question c'était par
rapport
[Musique]
au
bloc soviétique et bloc américain qui
fait que le bloc soviétique qu'est ce
qui fait qu'en d'après vous que le bloc
soviétique
est-ce que c'était pas idéologie ou par
moyens qui n'a pas utilisé le
bombardement au
même au même titre que les américains
staline avait très vite considéré y
qualifier larmes aériennes comme ça il a
qualifié d' armes bourgeoise donc il
avait commencé pour sa propagande pour
la pro b g du régime flatté des grandes
compagnies aériennes enfin des pannes et
compagnie mais ces ingénieurs comme du
pôle f&c qui ont très vite
fabriquer des phénomènes où lille avait
je crois en 1920 les plus grands avions
il battait les records et puis d'un coup
ce jeu serait pas pour dire il n'a pas
cru à cette arme il a pas investi
là-dedans et je crois que l'élément de
réponse c'est qu'il disposait d'une
démographie importante
il sait que la russie est un territoire
immense et qu'il avait d'autres donc
d'autre moyen de
2 2 se défend d'attaquer
autre chose
il
comme on le dit dans le film larmes
aérienne nécessite énormément
d'investissement et les avertissent les
investissements il les a il les a
consacrés aux chars d'assaut je crois
qu'il ya une autre un autre élément de
réponse c'est que cette question du
bombardement est très discutée hitler
n'y croit pas lui-même dans un premier
temps
les avions qui sont fabriqués par
l'allemagne sont des avions de
taille moyenne rapport à ce qu'ils vont
être reçus par la suite capable d'amener
en nombre une quantité de bombes très
très limité pour détruire des objets des
objectifs tactiques
et pas pour anéantir des villes
voilà donc c'est une arme qui est
qui est flatté par comme vous le disais
tout à l'heure quelques quelques
officiers dans les différentes armées de
l'air marshall aux états unis mais qui a
beaucoup du mal beaucoup de mal avant la
avant cette guerre va ce conflit-là à la
faire passer comme larmes de l'avenir
mais staline donc de ce côté il ya comme
si vous voulez avec avec un avion avec
un avion de combat je me bombardier en
chasseur bombardier pourrait faire trois
choses soit vous faites qu'on appelle de
l'appui c'est à dire que vous combinez
cela avec
l'action de forces terrestres au sol
donc bombardé devant vous vous les aidez
dans comme de l'artillerie vous les
aidez à dents de leur mission soit vous
faites deuxième catégorie de mission un
peu plus en arrière vous faites des
missions on appelle ça des missions
d'interdiction c'est là que vous allez
gêné l'armée adverse vous allez détruire
la logistique vous avez détruit leurs
dépenses à détruire des routes donc
c'est au delà du champ de bataille
lui-même mais c'est au profit quand même
de la bataille
et puis ce qu'on appelle le bon réalité
les frappes stratégique dans le haut
sens pour en aviateurs de la frapper dit
stratégie parce que c'est une frappe en
profondeur et qu'il a pour le coup
frappe sur sur le reste du pays sur les
dix régions sur l'entraînement sur
l'économie sur les américains ont défini
un certain nombre de cercle comme ça de
frappe bon en matière de doctrine
militaire les soviétiques par exemple ne
n'ont jamais envisagé sérieusement de
frappe dans la profondeur pour eux la
mayenne c'est la super artillerie et
c'est ça doit aider des opérations qui
sont en cours au sol et
les russes celui dicton jamais fait de
véritablement de campagne aérienne même
en syrie actuellement et ils font pas de
campagne à quelques frappes sait ça
relève plus des frappes symbolique ou de
la propagande en profondeur sur l'état
islamique par exemple qui est en
profondeur mais tout le reste c'est dans
le cadre d'opération précise
aéroterrestre on va dire donc c'est
celle ci une question de culture
stratégique usé tout à l'heure la france
et puis ça demande beaucoup de moyens on
sait faire un lancer une campagne
aérienne actuellement une grande
compagnie aérienne donc avec des
milliers de frappe
dans tout l'ensemble d'un système en
réalité il ya que actuellement il ya que
les américains qui sont capables de le
faire et
les israéliens à leurs frontières
sinon aucun pays au monde moralité qui
est capable de mener une campagne
aérienne et si je peux apporter un
dernier élément c'est une hypothèse mais
j'imagine que pour l'urss enfin
l'intérêt de la seconde guerre mondiale
c'est aussi de progresser sur le fond
dont deux sur le front de l'europe de
l'est et d'imposer lors leur domination
politique et donc pour ça j'imagine que
c'était plus opportun pour eux deux des
rapports une occupation militaire
terrestre afin de prendre le contrôle
aussi est politiquement de l'europe de
l'est
bien comprendre que de toute façon
militairement il faut il faut que
quelqu'un plantant un drapeau quelque
part on n'a pas les très rares que on
est à éviter cela par l'exemple de la
libye mais la libye ce sont d'abord des
gens qui combattait des libyens qui
combattait la guerre s'est terminée
lorsqu'ils ont pris tripoli et ils ont
ils ont tué tué kadhafi voilà cent sans
ces gens au sol non serait toujours en
train de bombarder
ce qu'il ya d'autres questions
c'est une question posée je crois que
oui
merci en préambule à ma question je dois
dire que ce que j'ai beaucoup apprécié
dans le film c'est un équilibre entre
s'adresser notre intelligence et
s'adresser à nos émotions
ma question est la suivante ne croyez
vous pas que cette histoire de choix est
la marque du déséquilibre qui lient à
nos civilisations que peu près un siècle
entre les émotions et le raisonnement
je veux dire par là que
les actions qui ont été décidées on
était beaucoup plus
d'espacé sur des sentiments sur des
dogmes beaucoup plus que sur des
raisonnements qui aurait utiliserait
l'intelligence
juste un mot dans le film on a dit qu'il
suffisait pour obtenir le plus grande
partie des résultats des bombardements
il suffisait de bombarder les
approvisionnements de pétrole et
certaines boîtes communication donc est
ce que ce n'est pas ce déséquilibre
entre l' usage de la raison et l' usage
des émotions qui est à l'origine de nos
choix
je ne sais pas si j'ai la réponse à
cette question complexe mais en tout cas
c'est sûr que on voit bien que même dans
la tête des stratèges tous bouscule un
petit peu c'était que dans le
bombardement et en tout cas disons vue
d'angleterre c'est sûr qu'il y a
il ya une espèce de
envie de rendre coup pour coup de désir
de revanche qui est complètement lié à
une émotion c'est à dire que le
bombardement de l'allemagne
politiquement et un succès pour
churchill à l'inter de l'angleterre
retient qu'il ya quelque chose qui est
de l'ordre de l'émotion et après il y a
il ya
yaya il ya également quelque chose qui
est de l'ordre de la fascination pour
cette aide pour cette arme dans laquelle
dans laquelle les stratèges de
l'entre-deux-guerres même désespoir des
espoirs complètement complètement fou et
et déraisonnable et en même temps il ya
ya ce raisonnement et je pense que c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui est typique de de cette période là
c'est que le
[Musique]
voilà je sais plus du tout ce que je
disais et j'avais mes mais ouais je sais
plus très bien ce que je disais mais en
tout cas il ya quelque chose qu'il y à
bien en tout cas dans dans le
bombardement quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre de 2,2 la fascination et et en
même temps quelque chose qui qui a
mobilisé des cerveaux
et des
pas seulement je ne dirais pas seulement
une intelligence technologique c'est
michel goya tout à l'heure évoqué la
douane cette idée de cercles
concentriques c'est à dire que c'est
c'est une guerre qui oblige à penser
comment fonctionne une nation en fait et
c'est une guerre qui oblige avant une
représentation du monde et 7,7 et voilà
et tout ça ça a été une ça a été une
je sais pas je sais plus troublant suite
mais en tout cas il ya quelque chose qui
peut qui se limite pas la technologie
autrement dit le raisonnement ne
consiste pas juste à savoir à faire des
bombardiers de plus en plus gros le
raisonnement consiste à comprendre
comment crack comment on obtient la
coercition comme on tord le bras à
quelqu'un voilà
d'ailleurs c'est quand même intéressant
c'est ce que vont très bien dans un film
c'est qu'on voit toujours aujourd'hui
cette volonté d'une approche
scientifique de la guerre qui est fait
avec des modèles avec des chiffres avec
b et alors qu'en fait toutes les études
montrent que la non robuste est
précisément des méthodes scientifiques
de la gale et qu'au fond c'est quand
même du domaine de la politique c'est à
dire aussi la croyance donc sur ce merci
beaucoup merci d'être resté aussi tard
accident
ça y est